tu as fait particulière il n'y avait pas
de maquis les armes de la résistance
était d'abord la propagande les journaux
clandestins
l'action directe individuelle contre les
allemands et bien entendu le sabotage
par exemple de leur moyen de transport
bien entendu il n'a pas été possible de
filmer au moment où se déroulait ses
actes de résistance les acteurs de ces
actes pour des raisons de sécurité bien
compréhensible aussi en vous présentant
le récit de ce qui allait s'insurger le
19 août 1944 contre les allemands vous
ne disposerez vous ne verrez que peu
d'image mais je pense que on regarde
l'exceptionnelle qualité
les témoignages recueillis vous nous en
excuser en même temps que vous le
comprendrez
oh
solitaire contempler la capitale depuis
la terrasse du palais de chaillot au
matin du 23 juin 1940 il était loin
d'imaginer que 50 mois après jour pour
jour
ces soldats capitulerait dans pas
en entendant pétards la radio la
première fois quand il a annoncé la
justice la pensée n'est pas venu fait
choquant qu'on pouvait faire autre chose
que de résister tout de suite c'est à
dire de faire tout fait tout ce qui
était attendu
je dois dire que dans toute la période
où j'ai agi dans le cadre de la
résistance gd sans exception tous les
gens qui étaient contre les allemands
c'était une condition sinequanone est
suffisante
il y avait ceux qui pensaient qu'il
fallait de gros maquis expédiait des
gens province et qu'ils soient dans les
maquis fixés nous nous étions contre
nous étions compte pour la simple raison
qu'en face des avions des chars et de
déploiement des forces de l'ennemi
on ne pouvait utiliser que la guérilla
sur les petits groupes
le conte parade à la baule la boule de
mercure qui se forme qui sont à
saisissable qu'on peut pas saisir voilà
les membres de notre réseau
il ya ceux livrés essentiellement le
d'abord publia jon hamm c'est ça a été
l'action ville d essentiellement vide et
le journal de résistance deuxièmement
l'évasion évasion évasion d'anglais et
les évasions de prisonniers de guerre
nous sommes tous occupés d'évasion et
puis alors forcément en faisant tout ce
travail il y avait des quantités de
renseignements qui nous arrive est dans
l'humain dans une salle y ont
littéralement pas quoi faire ce qui fait
que nous avons été amenés aussi par la
force des choses à envoyer nos
informations à londres le sabotage il
faut dire c'était une chose absolument
variés à la fois organisé puisque on a
eu nos groupes de sabotage et de
destruction organisée et il y avait
aussi des campagnes de sa brutale et y
avait également des gens qui sabotait
quand il le pouvait
le type qui dans une usine pareil
l'ancien bull ont à moitié il a besoin
de directives
il est lui-même et la plupart des
sabotages nous ne pouvions pas les
contrôler quand on essayait de recenser
ça veut dire qu'il y avait des
initiatives personnelles
tandis que la vie à paris étaient
apparemment sains changer un certain
nombre de parisiens chercher le moyen de
faire quelque chose nombreux furent ceux
qui agir individuellement beaucoup
n'étaient pas dans la clandestinité
mais il s'agissait tout de même
rapidement distribuant des feuilles
dactylographiées qui révélait des
nouvelles interviews et pour fait la
mention à copier 20 points et à faire
circuler
l'action armée elle était employée pas
seulement par des gens qui étaient
totalement clandestin
il y avait des résistants qui pouvait
tenir en pour le coup légalement et tant
qu'il pouvait tenir le coup légalement
on les laissait légaux et une passe et
comme on disait dans le brouillard que
quand il y avait plus moyen de faire
autrement
depuis quarante il nous fallait bien des
papiers pour passer au travers à travers
les rafles et celle ci s'entassent et
sylvia qui voyez ans est monté sur des
bobines de fil par conséquent c'était
vraiment de la fabrication artisanale et
ça c'était fait pour des papiers en
général originaires de province pour
paris s'était pas les meilleures
faire de faux papiers restait certes
dangereux mais était presque devenue
chose courante
c'est pâti en sauver de nombreux
français mais pour bien d'autres très
actif dans la clandestinité
cela ne suffisait pas comment avez vous
été appréhendé par les allemands alors
moi j'ai été arrêté à la gare de nyon et
j'avais rendez vous avec un traître qui
était un prêtre alors à la gare de la
bastille et nous avons donc parcouru
cette soupe distance entre la gare
d'investiguer la gare de lyon à 3 nous
étions un autre garçon qui était lui à
jean et d'un groupe de la texture cialis
le prêtre en question et moi même et
nous avons marché tous les trois à pied
jusqu'à la gare de lyon et je me
souviens que à mi chemin entre la garde
le pastis et la gare de nyon
j'ai eut brusquement un sentiment
irrationnel un sentiment de danger et je
me suis tourné vers le berceau de liesse
et je lui ai dit partait immédiatement
et je me souviens qui m'a regardé avec
des yeux
elle vit
non non pas du tout au contraire des
mesures des yeux des yeux du pagnol
breton le gentil comme ça puis il est
parti
et alors moi j'ai continué avec anne
heche est arrivé à la gare de lyon au
guichet avait soi-disant partir en zone
libre
il m'a tendu la main
j'ai vu dans ses yeux une expression de
jubilation qui m'a terriblement
inquiétée je me suis dit ce type là est
attendu et je ne devrais pas avoir à
faire je devrai éviter d'avoir à faire
avec lui mais je croyais que c'était un
tordu par mme par romantisme romantisme
de la résistance alors qu'en réalité
c'était un type qui savait c'est
classique
il avait lu l'évangile et ils se
voyaient dans le personnage de judas ce
qui n'était d'ailleurs je lui ai parlé
tout à l'heure des différentes actions
de la propagande de l'action populaire
dans les entreprises y avait aussi
action des femmes on pourrait dire pour
le ravitaillement etc
il y avait beaucoup de fond de l'action
mais y'avait aussi l'action armée avait
également cette brochure là qui
s'intitule scouts ou et on faisait des
brochures de ce genre avec une
couverture bidon pour passer plus
facilement devant la police et celle ci
elle avait trait à l'utilisateur briques
à sion et à l'utilisation des armes
alors vous y trouverez là dedans le
matériel mans un matériel américain de
matériel français et le matériel
artisanale
alors on se battait avec ces armes là à
ben woillet nous avions un stand
évidemment récupération nous avions le 7
65 qui vous en avions récupéré dans tous
les sens nous avions le 6 35
et puis aussi il faut le dire la
bataille de paris s'est fait avec les
britain molotov chez chez certains que
si vous taillez chance mais ryan ac ont
joué un rôle prépondérant rêver quelques
infos ce qui faisait son effet depuis le
printemps 43 nous avions constitué ce
que l'on a appelé le comité parisien
libération qui était un organisme
d'union de tous les mouvements de
résistance mais on n'était pas toujours
unis surtout faut reconnaître que sur un
certain nombre de questions sur
l'essentiel nous étions unis d'ailleurs
on était uni notamment à partir du
programme du conseil national de la
résistance et de la partie sur les
les choses à appliquer immédiatement
avant la libération
c'est à dire sur les questions d'accès
aux ce qui était une victoire sur
l'attentisme déjà pour repousser les
allemands qui refluaient sur paris il
fallait avant tout défendre les ponts
des chefs de région en fait celui ci
s'en occuper l'objectif pour les francs
tireurs et partisans de ce secteur était
de barrer la route à la viiie armée qui
refluaient de normandie et qui voulaient
par buzz ont occupé la région nord de
paris en chanson par le poison les
actions sur nombreuses conflans sainte
honorine
ou comme on vend tout est vert à
l'opération
le mont valérien qui sont occupées par
moteur évidemment les chantiers
c'est peu avant la suite des
préparations de l'insurrection que ryter
a été attaqué par un groupe des faits
perry terre c'était le chef du st au
service du travail obligatoire en france
que sur les champs elysées sous la
conduite de josé pecten un autocar
d'officiers allemands a été retrouvé à
quatre pattes
sion résistance et c'est très sensible
dans les entreprises mais ce sont les
cheminots qui furent parmi les plus
actifs et les plus efficaces
ils ont subi de lourdes pertes rien que
de la région parisienne
les premières l'avion il y a eu des
débrayages
il y a eu des sabotages de masse coupage
de frein coupage de tuyaux de freins
boîte
boîtes d'essieux sablé et c'est un
travail de masse d'abord de l'ensemble
pas de l'enfant mais d'une grande partie
d'esprit nous suggère lagarde cardinet
qui était qui s'est particulièrement
illustré non c'est pas particulièrement
illustré mais c'est ici que les premiers
trains ont été arrêtés
et pourquoi ont ils été hérités ici
parce que nous avions des forces ici
compte tenu des dépôts des batignolles
qui secouera côté contenu des ateliers
de levallois qui coupait à eux seuls un
millier de cheminots et qui se sont
rendus ici sur les voies pour arrêter
les trains d'une part et d'autre part
parce que cardinet se situe à côté de la
grande gare de salazar qui débite des
milliers et des milliers de voyageurs
par jour
et le début de juillet 1944 une série de
manifestations et d'appels divers ont
préparé l'insurrection une manifestation
particulièrement importante c'est celle
là première manifestation qui a été
appelé publiquement et qui a lieu à
belleville on a apprécié à peu près à
vingt mille personnes le nombre de
participants mais pour la trois et on a
appelé publiquement
il y avait même des gens qui croyaient
que c'était une aventure bien sûr on
leur ait fait un mois plus tôt c'était
une aventure mais le moment été choisi
il fallait le faire parce qu'il fallait
aguerris aussi les gens alors la
manifestation ait lieu en carré pour la
première fois par des ff pas des ftp
larmes apparente
les journaux clandestins entretenir le
moral des parisiens dans la tente de
leur libération
tandis que l'on s'apprêtait à livrer
l'ultime combat au camp de ravensbrück
germaine tillon sentais que c'était pour
aujourd'hui
il ya eu un certain jeu de cet été là je
vois encore un soleil gros comme ça au
raz de l'horizon et je me suis dit que
pour moi c'est aujourd'hui la prise de
paris et ça a été quelque chose de
formidable parce qu'au fond c'est vrai
que nous vivons tous sous someone paris
n'est pas la france que vous savez bien
mais la prise de paris a été quand même
le symbole de l'effondrement français et
la libération de paris a été le symbole
de la libération de la france